from his books I imagine bear got to be
a frail disappointed old man who had
lost several of his children and never
recovered and so I would read I would
sing his prose to myself more Dolce more
lent or perhaps than it was written and
the simplest sentence spoke to me with a
more tender intonation above all else I
loved his philosophy I had pledged
myself to it for life it made me
impatient to reach the age when I would
enter secondary school and enroll in the
classical philosophy but I did not want
to do anything else there but live
according to bear God's ideas
exclusively and had I been told that the
metaphysicians to whom I would be
devoting myself by then would not
resemble him at all I would have felt
the despair of a lover who wants his
love to be lifelong and to whom one
talks about the other mistresses that
will come later one Sunday as i was
reading in the garden i was disturbed by
swine who had come to see my parents
what are you reading may I look well
well backups now who told you about his
books I said it was blocked I yes the
boy I saw here once who looked so much
like the portrait of Matt Matt second by
Bellini oh it's quite striking he has
the same circumflex eyebrows the same
curve knows the same cutting cheekbones
when he was when he has a goatee he'll
be the same person well he has good
taste in any case because bear got is
quite enchanting and seeing how much I
appeared to admire records swan who had
never talked about the people he knew
out of kindness made an exception and
said to me I know him quite well if you
would like him to write a few words in
the front of your book I could ask him I
did not dare accept his offer but ask
Swan some questions about Becca
could you tell me which is his favorite
actor actor I don't know but I do know
that he doesn't consider any man on
stage equal to laverna he puts her above
everyone else have you seen her no
Monsieur my parents don't allow me to go
to the theater that's unfortunate you
ought to ask them that their mind
feather in lacede is only an actress you
might say but you know I'm not much of a
believer in the hierarchy of the Arts
and I noticed as had often struck me in
his conversations with my grandmother's
sisters that when he talked about
serious things when he used an
expression that seemed to imply an
opinion about an important subject he
took care to isolate it in a tone of
voice that was particularly mechanical
and ironic as though he had put it in
between quotation marks see me not to
want to take responsibility for it as
though saying hierarchy you know as it's
called by silly people but then if it
was so silly why did he say hierarchy a
moment later he had it it will give you
a noble vision of it as any map
masterpiece I don't know really as he
began to laugh the queen of shot until
then his horror of ever expressing a
serious opinion had seemed to me think
that must be elegant and Parisian and
that was the opposite of the provincial
dogmatism of my grandmother's sisters
and I also suspect that it was a form of
wit in the social circles in which Swan
moved where reacting against the
lyricism of earlier generations they
went to an extreme in rehabilitating
those small precise facts formerly
reputed to be vulgar and prescribed fine
phrases but now I found something
shocking in his attitude and this
attitude of swans towards things it
appeared that he dared not have an
opinion and was it is easy only when he
could with
particulars accuracy offers some precise
piece of information but if that was the
case he did not realize that to
postulate that the accuracy of these
details was important was to profess an
opinion I thought again of the dinner at
which I was so sad because mama would
not be coming up to my room and at which
he had said that the balls given by the
press s billion were of no importance
whatsoever but it was to just this sort
of pleasure that he devoted his life I
found all this contradictory for what
other lifetime was he reserving the
moment when he would at last say
seriously what he thought of things
formulate opinions that he did not have
to put between quotation marks and no
longer indulge with grant ilyas
politeness in occupations which he
declared at the same time to be
ridiculous I also noticed in the way
Swan talked to me about bear gods
something that was on the other hand not
peculiar to him but shared at the same
time by all the writers admirers by my
mother's friends by dr. do boond Oh boom
boom like Swan they said about Burke
oath he's quite enchanting so individual
he has his own way of saying things
which is a little overly elaborate but
so pleasing you don't need to see the
signature you know right away that it's
by him but none of them would have gone
so far as to say he's a great writer he
has a great talent they did not even say
he had talent they did not say because
they did not know it we are very slow to
recognize in the particular features of
a new writer the model that is labeled
great talent in our Museum of general
ideas precisely because these features
are new we do not think they fully
resemble what we call Talent instead we
talked about originality charm delicacy
strength and then one day we realize
that all of this is
fact are there any books by their God in
which he talks about libere may I ask
mr. Swamy I think so in his slim little
volume on haseen but it must be out of
print there may have been a reissue
though I'll find out I can also ask
forgot anything you like there isn't a
week in the whole year that he doesn't
come to dinner at our house he's my
daughter's greatest friend they go off
together visiting old towns cathedrals
castles since I had no notion of social
hierarchy for a long time the fact that
my father found it impossible for us to
associate with Madame and Mademoiselle
Swann had had the effect above all by
making me imagine a great distance
between them and us of it giving them
prestige in my eyes I was sorry my
mother did not dye her hair and read in
her lips as i have heard our neighbors
madam says well I say that my life's
wanted in order to please not her
husband but Monsieur nisha and I thought
we must be an object of scorn tour which
distressed me most of all because when
was this one who from what I had been
told was such a pretty little girl and
about whom I had often dreamed giving
her each time the same arbitrary and
charming face but when I learned that
day that man was a swan was a creature
of so rare a conditioning bathing as
though in her natural element in the
midst of such privileges that when she
asked her parents if anyone was coming
to dinner she would be answered by the
syllables filled with light by the name
of the golden dinner guests who was for
her only an old friend of the family
Becker that for her the intimate talk at
the table the equivalent for me of my
great aunt's conversation would be bad
God's Word all on all the subjects he
had not been able to broach in his books
and on which I would have liked to hear
and pronounce his organs and that lastly
when she went to visit other towns
he would walk along next to her unknown
and glorious like the gods who descended
among mortals then I was conscious both
of the worth of a creature like
Mademoiselle Swan and also of how crude
and ignorant I mean I would appear to
her and I felt so keenly the sweetness
and the impossibility of my being her
friend that I was filled with both
desire and despair most often now when I
thought of her I would see her in front
of a cathedral porch explaining to me
what the statues signified and which and
with a smile that said good things about
me introducing me to her friend tobacco
and always the charm of all those ideas
awakened in me by the cathedrals the
charm of the hills of either falls and
the plains of Normandy cast its glimmers
over the picture I was forming of
Mademoiselle Swan this was what is meant
to be on the point of falling in love
with her our belief that a person takes
part in an unknown life which with which
his or her love would allow us to enter
is of all the love demands in order to
come into being what it prizes the most
and what makes it care little for the
rest even women who claim to judge a man
by his appearance alone see the
appearance as the emanation of a special
life this is why they love soldiers
fireman the uniform makes them less
particular about her face they think
that under the breastplate they are
kissing a different heart adventurous
and sweet and a young sovereign a crown
prince may make the most flattering
conquests in the foreign countries he
visits without needing the regular
profile that would perhaps be
indispensable to a stockbroker